The last week I was interviewed for an upcoming
publication and one of the questions I was
asked was, what do you think is [inaudible]
really important right now that is not getting
the attention that it deserves?
And my mind went immediately to the courts
and I hope that this part of the interview
makes it into the article that should be published
later this week.
I'll make sure to share it with you when it
is because while impeachment continues to
get attention, which it should, as Trump's
foibles overseas with our allies continue
to be discussed, which they should, the courts
are increasingly under the oversight of Trump
appointed judges and they are going to ruin
this country for decades to come.
Now, Donald Trump in conjunction with the
truly sickening, disgusting hyper-partisan
clown, Kentucky Senator Mitch McConnell, have
been working together to confirm what they
have a goal of being 182 judges by the end
of this year.
Federal judges who are really important to
our judicial system, and this gets very little
attention.
These are lifetime appointments.
Donald Trump is on track to put nearly twice
as many of these judges as president Obama
had at this point in his presidency.
The Supreme court picks get a lot of attention
and they should, but most cases don't get
to the Supreme court.
The number of cases that in the aggregate
these federal court judges are going to decide
on a dwarfs by orders of magnitude.
The number of cases that the Supreme court
is going to decide on.
Lots of the judges that are being nominated
and actually confirmed are getting the rating
of straight up not qualified from the American
bar association.
One example is for 46 year old Lawrence van
Dyke who was just confirmed by the Mitch McConnell
run Senate.
Every single one of these appointments is
terrible, but there are also tipping points
that go beyond just another judge here or
another judge there, and I apologize for punching
my mic.
I'm just getting very wound up about this.
Another example, the ninth circuit court as
a whole is historically a left leaning court.
There are 29 seats on that court.
13 are currently Republican seats.
10 of those 13 Republican seats are Trump
appointed.
Even the ninth circuit court is increasingly
Trumpian and Republicans are United in favor
of these horrible and often unqualified judges.
For example, everyone other than Senator Susan
Collins voted to confirm Sarah Pitt lik Sarah
Pitt lick is completely and totally opposed
to abortion.
She considers the destruction of an embryo,
a quote killing.
She considers that a killing.
She has never tried a single case, but she
will have a lifetime seat on a United States
district court in Missouri.
She was also rated not qualified by the American
bar association.
Now, I could go on and on with examples, but
the big picture is what matters here.
First of all, this is a reminder, once again,
not that we needed it.
If you thought Hillary would have been just
as bad as Trump, no one should listen to you
ever again and the courts were high on the
list of why.
That was a very, very incorrect analysis at
the time and I've continued to make it since
now.
The worldwide embarrassment, the bogus trade
war that's also on the list, but the courts
were at the top of the list from the beginning.
Number two, this is a reminder that Donald
Trump's impact will continue long beyond his
presidency.
This is something we've been talking about
lately and the courts are a big part of that
as well.
Now I hesitate to call impeachment a distraction
from this because number one, impeachment
is really important.
Even if it fails, impeachment is a congressional
duty.
When the facts warranted you impeach, you
don't say, well, it's going to distract from
this, that or the other thing, but number
two, the judge stuff would be happening with
or without impeachment and other than no taking
back the Senate, we would have little way
to stop what is going on with judges, but
there could be more coverage because if every
time one of these completely and totally unqualified
judges was nominated, we had massive public
outcry and coverage on corporate media.
It might shame the Trump administration and
to nominating at least marginally more qualified
and less crazy people maybe.
But the most important thing about this is
getting coverage so that it puts it in people's
minds as something to think about.
When you consider who to vote for in November
of 2020 imagine that you are one of those
people who incorrectly thought back in 2016
Trump, Hillary, whatever.
It's all the same.
If you recognize that one of the areas where
that analysis was so wrong, I mean it was
a weaponized argument, it was so wrong and
toxic.
If you recognize that with judges, that argument
fell very short.
If that is repeated now, it would be in your
mind when you think about 2020 and maybe it
gets you not to stay home, but to go out and
vote for somebody who will help remove Donald
Trump, where where your vote will help remove
Donald Trump.
That is why we have to make sure people understand
the long lasting impact of this.
We have to continue to repeat that.
This issue of judges every month is getting
worse.
I think it was two months ago on the bonus
show, we said a 25% of judges at some level,
I don't remember exactly what it was, have
now been selected by Donald Trump.
Donald Trump's judgment about who to select
when he doesn't give it to some other conservative
group or special interest group and actually
is picking people himself.
It's disastrous.
It's absolutely and completely disastrous.
So we can't forget about this.
I hope it's part of this article that is coming
out about the David Pakman show in a few days,
which I will share with you on social media
and I'm going to renew my efforts to continue
talking about this on the show.